these Iranian women dress up as men to
sneak into soccer stadiums women have
been barred from attending matches since
Iran's 1979 Islamic Revolution the
disguised women are risking arrest to
cheer on their favorite teams had a
fraud on volume according family nature
that Allah may Allah grant a very
suitable to Iran donation reading as
Hamas or Nicky tribe me train here the
hyena study home harbor t-mobile's going
on at a match in october between iran
and bolivia word spread that women would
be let in for the first time in almost
40 years but the victorious mood was
short-lived authorities hand-picked a
group of just 100 women to let in
including relatives of national team
players and female soccer players doors
anemone fish allah khair iran hostel on
as in marathi I got an understudy on
rocky the Nocona
Mahamaya estimate motor a dress a dress
and a football around Asia hope received
our holiday Muhammad amber C 4 AF see
how special FIFA fairy day in final year
that was in a few polygons on our hora
after the match hopes for change
dwindled Iran's chief prosecutor
condemned the presence of women at games
arguing that if a woman watches
half-naked men in athletic attire it
will lead to sin he ordered the
prosecution of stadium officials who
allow women into men's sporting events
it was a setback for the activists
possible intruder who they can master
roshi down no more around him without my
cell phone only with your mom so I don't
have any meeting time on which physical
medium is analyzed when we were in took
over Tottenham our devices coverage in
my pocket team a rotational polymer
Jesus the ideas in a neighborhood you
know Gucci John burning her for now the
ladies are sticking with fake beards
while they keep up their fight
you